for young people to have opportunities
we need to help them develop and people
talk about leadership but the first most
important thing about leadership is
understanding yourself your own
strengths maybe your own weaknesses as
well the things that you prefer and the
things that you find difficult and I
think what all of the young people on
the course find out is a lot more about
themselves which then it helps them to
go and lead other people and did you
draw on your own personal experience in
thinking that I can contribute something
to this yeah I think when you are in a
position where you're leading national
football team thankfully we've had good
results so people pay a little bit more
attention maybe to the way that you lead
and maybe there's a perception that you
have to be a certain character to be a
leader or to be in charge when actually
that personality can take all different
sorts of forms so you don't have to be
one type one personality type to be able
to lead other people successfully and
can you draw do draw in your involvement
in what happens in sport in football
what's happened to you with England you
can draw on that yeah I think it's
important when you're working with young
people that they recognize not only that
it's it's possible to succeed but that
before the success there's a lot of hard
learning and there's a lot of difficult
times and a lot of failures along the
way and I think it's fine to be open
about those things because that's part
of improvement and I think when you're
young you're working all of those things
out in your life you don't know maybe
necessarily exactly what you want to do
and you assume that everybody that's
older and appears successful on the
outside that life's been a breeze for
them and generally speaking all the
successful people I've ever met that
hasn't been the case
and because leadership is about how you
deal with those not failures but when
things don't go according to plan
I mean you've you with England
incredible success do you kind of brace
yourself for when the results are not
quite so good I mean do you do you sort
of look ahead and think how am I gonna
deal with that well I've had fair amount
of failure as well with so I'm pretty
well adapted to what that might be and
you you know that for every success
there will be difficult times but as a
leader you've got to take the rest of
the group through those difficult times
and keep them on track keep them focused
on the vision ahead and lead them
through those difficult spells they're
the biggest challenges for leaders that
people lose confidence in the plan if
you're if you're losing matches or if
there's difficult moments but there are
lots of things you could do when it
comes to sort of charities or helping
organizations what is a what is it about
this that you think that makes it
something where you can really
contribute and what are you going to be
doing yeah so this is I've worked with
the Prince's Trust for over 10 years
anyway so I have a good association and
a good understanding of the areas of of
their work I think it's so important to
invest in young people that is it's
obvious but they are the future of our
country and the more that we can develop
leaders and the more that we can give
young people confidence and then they
can go out and an opportunity then we're
affecting everything that happens in our
country so I'm in a position where
because of the role I mean I think I can
make a difference and I'm also working
with young people of this age every day
of my working life so and just finally
on this what would be your key message
then to maybe a young person who doesn't
feel confident even to apply for a you
know to come on a program like this what
would be your message to them yeah that
I think everybody in the world has
insecurities everybody and very often
that inhibits us from doing what might
be possible and really going for things
so sometimes the most difficult thing is
to pick up the phone and enroll in a
course
or to approach somebody to go on a
course and if you can make that step
then I think the experience of coming
and taking part in that leadership
journey will give them great skills for
the rest of their lives
all right let's talk briefly about
football I mean it's been the most
extraordinary 48 hours can you quite
believe what you witnessed with these
two wins by Liverpool and Tottenham well
I was at Manchester City on Monday so I
thought that was a incredible twist in
itself I was an Enfield on Tuesday so
left there thinking I'd seen one of the
most things I mean I've been in football
30 years one of the most incredible
nights I can remember for it then to be
backed up by Tottenham on Wednesday was
phenomenal I mean huge credit to both
managers in different circumstances
they've achieved incredible seasons and
from an England perspective brilliant
for all of our players that they're
having these experiences in big matches
where they're having to play under
pressure and they've come out
successfully is it good for England
though because you've got this issue now
haven't you it lands you in a bit of
trouble with the dates the Champions
League final on June the 1st you've got
the game semi-final of the National
League on the six so how much of a
headache is that for you then well it's
mate it's making things more complicated
that's for sure because reality is we
all get seven or eight of those players
three days before our semi finals so you
have great ideas as a manager of
planning things and working with the
team and in truth we'll have half of our
squad that won't be with us until three
days before so more complicated but
brilliant for for the players and
long-term for England we need them in
those matches and our job as their staff
is to adapt to those changes and make
sure that we're still prepared for the
semi-final with Holland so who's gonna
win a Champions League well thanks a
tricky one lately it is really difficult
because I think Liverpool have won the
matches between the two this year
but I've been the Champions League
matches I've been at this year I was in
Paris when Manchester United won which I
went there not thinking that was going
to happen I went to Anfield not thinking
that was going to happen it was saw
Spurs win against Manchester City which
certainly you know two minutes from the
end didn't look like it was going to
happen so it's been a remarkable year in
that competition and anything is
possible and luckily I don't care
actually as long as the English players
come through play well and stay fit then
I'm happy yeah
and just finally the Women's World Cup I
mean you know you've had a great World
Cup just recently last year what is your
message to them well they're ready you
know they're very they've got a nice
blend of some experienced players who've
been two World Cups before quite a few
of them have over a hundred caps you
know they were doing this before us they
were in a semi final four years ago so
and they've got some good young players
coming through as well so hugely
exciting summer for them we're all
supportive of what they're going to do
and I've my only advice would be to
enjoy it in the way that we did